[Music]
welcome back to careful boys hey what's
up guys hey what's up we got with us a
very careful boy named tj lee who is in
the hot seat you guys know about this
segment tj lee is a friend of mine he's
quest crew he is a friend i talked about
in a past video when i was uh
telling this long story about this
massive car accident that i was in that
he was also in where he got paralyzed
recovered and now helps other kids
recover from a lot of the same things
that he went through
good on you tj lee
hero a real jk hero and
for hot seat we like to start it kind of
cold and turn up the temperature
and as the temperature goes up that's
when we feel like hot and vulnerable but
before we get there let's start it off
with you guys spin on it first
let's start off with bart he has the
coldest
coldest question
so
let's say
you had to redesign dice
and it's a cube
what other shape would you prefer
what the [ __ ] is going on
it's been like vegas i'm like it should
have been a [ __ ] that other number
because the pyramid it will be a point
yeah you don't know what point odds are
odds are good as i'm getting kicked on
one of the sides
it's up to you yeah it's up to you what
number it is very stable though very
stable very stable dies good good odds
okay
nice nice answer all right um
when did you
and ryan first become friends
friends
i told you i told you you're the leader
leader of quest crew the leader of wait
you're the leader of quest crew fake
really no i know
that's what you think no there's no
leader there's no way when did you first
meet him and what was your first
impression of him you knew one of my
exes right
desiree no no i knew i just knew you
foreign
like 2 000 then how do you know aries
from anabella yeah he's my i've known
him since second grade well third grade
technically i knew his sister in second
grade i did
he says i stole his ball before school
started and then after after i had class
with him he's like she's like he's cool
he's like all right you cool dude you
know my sister so yeah oh tight that's
how that's how our story begins yeah our
connection goes
yeah yeah our connection is weird
because i met eris because he was
walking around montebello mall with a
shirt that said break it's like it had a
b-boy on it and then my uh the rest of
my crew was also at the mall they met
him and they go hey we just met this
dude with a break t-shirt we're gonna go
to his house and practice so then i went
over there i met him up we had a session
we instantly were just like best friends
and then this guy
was just kind of residually there
because he's from eris's circle and then
we all just meshed and we're like dude
let's go was he fat at the time that was
a bigger boy
how big were you
what was that it's like
five five seven two hundred pounds maybe
i
might skinny to make my way
like
with width and length when you buy pants
we're like the same or i had to buy like
adult pants when i was like since like
middle school
you've been fat all your life
not not anymore i'm sorry i'm still i'm
not you're looking at him right now
hey you always been this fat
[Laughter]
kid still yeah yeah
yeah oh dude that's a mentality for sure
yeah yeah it is yeah the foods you
choose what's that i treat other people
yeah
just like getting into a little hot seat
right now
turn it up just regulation just regular
[ __ ] we're still warming up but make
sure that you guys see the other video
where we actually talk about more of his
story so you know more otherwise i just
seem like a jerk okay
so you were talking about one of the
first things you know when you realize
that um it wasn't all paralyzed you
started coming back was you know your
penis
sensations right you started you know
stuff like that
when was uh
the like how long it take before number
one it was like kind of bad
we jacked off yeah where you started
actually at the hospital yes they get i
was happy i had another friend i had a
friend come by and i was like hey like
what can you handle it
can can you help me i just think you
know i just want to see so ryan jack you
all
we said we'd never
what heiress did that
he ain't down he died to help a brother
like that
wow somebody come by you had a
montebello haina come by
so the first time you came was through a
hand job and not even jacking off didn't
come but got a hand job yes why not you
did not come
[Laughter]
that's what she said i think that's more
of a physiological thing i don't know i
couldn't yeah but it got up and
everything was like my hair like tight
it's working
that's incredible i didn't know that did
you have to take off the catheter first
oh i was already off but then she had to
like undo my diaper which was kind of
weird
whoever she is slow down
were you guys talking at the time or
were you just like yo homie i got a
favor go home
you have tv raps hit pop tj bro
it could have been one of my exes
because there was a lot of friends that
came by a lot of hospital visits yeah
a lot of friends
staff was like hey you got another
friend i'm like
cool
he's like make sure you sign the log you
don't have any dude
friends you ask me this so so so so uh
[ __ ] bro
how was your
like
how like how was your dating life before
as a as a big dude uh
there was no dating life wow
i didn't know about that skill was right
i later on i was like oh i friend zoned
a bunch of people because i didn't know
anything oh so the girls actually liked
you but then you friends owned them no i
didn't know he was like import tutor boy
yeah i mean that's all kind of a weird
age anyway yeah
what's going on up so okay did you find
yourself
being a straight pamp when you became
paralyzed
like dude were you like oh classic
paralyzed pimples
classic yeah
i'm a spit game now because all these
girls [ __ ] like me now no you're
already up in the hospital bed and then
like how did you get how did you get a
[ __ ] favorite that was a big favor i
think that one but how do you actually
kevin is never it was never it was like
it's your favorite that's what i'm just
wondering like are you romantically
involved or anything like that because
it just sounds to me it's like i asked
anthony to jack me off in bed well you
got to throw me off a sandwich i got to
say anthony like he didn't even do it i
don't have any friends i got to say my
first name like that man my mom don't
call me that anthony all right
this is kind of like oh like what was
going on i was like hey like things have
been improving
and i i felt pain it could it's been it
was like so early on where even it did
it
mentally i couldn't feel anything i was
just like
all right that's cool oh that's
so much sexual is more like a scientific
science like nothing really happened i
was like
well at least there's pain i can't feel
the good part there's pain that's
something you're getting the hand john
was still kind of painful it was like
because it's the sensations like it
doesn't know what's going on so i'm just
like
okay so got it okay that's a good ex
let's just check that off it's there at
least i feel it it's there yeah
do you try the same with anal just to
make sure oh they got so they have to
put like suppositories in
all the time
because i couldn't poop because there's
no signals going up in there oh my god
they got like up bend over i was like
this is like jail like okay cool like
things that up in me i gotta do stuff i
don't want i have to eat at certain
times i was like they have to call you a
[ __ ] when they do it though yeah they
have to turn their eyes on
they hold your head yeah because they
kind of move my head so i'm like oh okay
there you go here we go tell me i'm a
good doctor yeah hold my pocket
all right so
i don't i don't do that supply store
anymore now
only for fun
do you feel like since since then your
dating life has gotten better uh
well now it's really great but it's been
a lot of like i would be too upfront
like hey gotta accidentally blah blah
they're like why are you telling me all
this and then we meet in person and then
they see this and they're like
oh it's like you can kind of see it and
it's like oh i'm like
okay because you went on some tinder
dates right there there's a lot of had
like a lot of tender nights but the ones
that i gotta make sure they're like
open-minded because he passed all that
and those were what do you mean what
they see like they see your like
disability or whatever it is and then
they have a disability
rocking around and then yeah like i
still walk around like all funky i see
you gotta like oh like i need help with
things with a limp yeah
do you ever ever like [ __ ] with them and
like you're you are balanced but you're
just like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
all the way down
not on the dates
maybe at the club but not at the
on the date parties
[Laughter]
that's like such a 90s [ __ ] dude
movie dude that's a bart move
[Laughter]
regular
stupid because that because balance has
always been issues still issued me so
it's not like
like for me it's like if that happens
more like oh i'm gonna like help me
rather than wow
i'm gonna [ __ ] die hurry the [ __ ] up
yeah
it's like it's a different like thinking
like oh [ __ ] go fall rather yeah oh hey
how's it going that's that's
drunk tj a little different but then
that's also because the drunker i get
the less balance i get so i'm just like
say i'm like haha i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm gonna fall i'm gonna fall on you
i'll follow regret
everybody gets something everybody gets
up like oh cool club's really packed
that's even better because i could just
bounce off everybody and get to where i
just picked it yeah yeah today's video
is brought to you by expressvpn you know
what i hate the most hmm
when you're like searching for stuff
and then you get hit with ads [ __ ]
constantly on your phone yeah and i know
it's connected yeah but i hate seeing
ads over and over and over and over and
over again and so far the only solution
i found is using the vpn because when
i'm doing it it thinks i'm somewhere
else
and i know most of you guys are just
thinking why don't you just use
incognito mode let me tell you something
incognito mode does not hydra activity
it doesn't matter what mode you use or
how many times you clear your browsing
history your internet service provider
can still see every single website that
you've ever visited that's why even when
i'm at home i never go online without
using expressvpn it doesn't matter who
your internet service provider is isps
in the u.s can legally sell your info to
ad companies expressvpn is an app that
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure servers so that
your isp cannot see the sites that you
visited expressvpn also keeps all of
your information secure by encrypting a
hundred percent of your data by using
the most powerful encryption available
most of the time i don't even realize
that i have expressvpn on it just runs
seamlessly in the background it's so
easy to use all you gotta do is tap that
one button and you're protected
expressvpn is available on all your
devices phones computers and even your
smart tv so there's no excuse for you to
not be using it protect your online
activity today by using the vpn that's
rated number one by business insider
visit our exclusive link with expert
visit our exclusive link expressvpn.com
off the record and you can get an extra
three months free on a one year package
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
off the record
expressvpn.com off the record to learn
more have you ever
had sex in the hospital no
but you got a hand job oh that's pretty
good i'm pretty badass dude
i don't think i've ever gotten a head
job ever yeah
[Laughter]
only in church
let's switch hot seats real quick i got
a couple questions
just ask me now dude
dancers probably know when okay this is
a little bit darker but you know you
went through something pretty crazy um
when you're paralyzed and you couldn't
really move they tried to sit you up and
you would and they let go and fall back
down did you ever have a point where
you felt like suicidal at all or like
man this life [ __ ] sucks i don't want
to live this life anymore no because i
had a lot of friends a lot of friends
come by and a lot of support that's the
biggest part when i tell them it's like
timing and support and then me just like
[ __ ] it there's nothing to lose
that helped me out cause like brian can
come by airs like friends always come
out on a daily where it's like cool like
hey check this out
and you're like they're like oh what
happened like you didn't see me i held
for like two seconds like yeah oh so i
get to kind of teach him about it and be
like look like oh like today's five
seconds like hey good job cause they see
like they've been coming by so much that
it could be like little wins and like in
the grand scheme of stuff for me i was
like yo check this out
uh i didn't hit my head and like yeah
that was that's the trick that was weird
to see like
to see those increments with you it's
like crazy because like when you know
someone for so long and that's not how
they move at all and he's relearning all
of his like babies like a baby yeah yeah
it's like dude i remember
just the way it used to normally be you
know and then
now it's like little tiny things are
like huge breakthroughs i'm right i told
you you probably won't get better you
just quit
i was like i'm gonna get you right okay
well i'm all the way over here two feet
away
there's a point where
i got an argument with my dad and then i
think you were there yeah i was just
like i was like like this and then after
that after like the argument was over my
dad was that's the last time i saw him
by the way i was like what it's my fault
what'd you do and then like afterwards i
was like yo that's the most i moved like
that's kind of cool that would make me
more angry it's like a movie
i remember that that's the i think that
was the worst thing i thought came from
that was because i i went to visit him
and i was just like i just walked in
and like him and his dad were like
fighting and i guess like he was blaming
you for something
and then that that's when you said i
don't know if you ever tell me this but
you were like
you like
you were like crying i was like dude
what happened and you said
you know the worst thing about being
paralyzed as i i can't go to another
room um yeah and so i can't get away
from this guy oh [ __ ]
um
at what point did you go did you ever
think like
do you have a moment when you're like
i'm paralyzed now this is my life
forever
and then it's kind of like i can't move
in the in the beginning because i
couldn't move at all but as soon as like
little things came up i was like
all right let's keep do you know how
long that moment of hope like in that
whole period of like just not being able
to wiggle nothing you just wait sitting
there and you're just like [ __ ]
um oh during that time i was just trying
to survive that's all it was yeah or
like just remembering things like oh if
i lay down too long of a pressure sore
but then after a while i was like hey
mom you're tired of pushing me around
don't call the nurse just like leave me
so i actually did have a pressure sore
like the size of a quarter on my ass or
just leaking blood out because i was
like just leave me alone like i was like
at this point like
i like i just didn't want to be a burden
to people and that's like even like now
when i like people ask her i'm like no i
got it i'm like a struggle yeah i think
yeah they're so different people
sometimes sometimes i'll make milky like
on those on those days mcdonald's
[ __ ] [ __ ] we've seen you melt it one
time though man
disneyland minus
that was like for us but this again i
i'll play i'll play jokes i'll play
jokes but he only does it for us but
like
all throughout the whole thing i've
never heard him like complain about it
like one time so uh when ryan was
telling us the story initially um it was
a third guy
uh and the other guy he had mentioned
never came by or visited one time
uh
what happened how did you feel about
that
at that point i was just like where is
he but
things are going so fast and like rehab
friends like everything like all the
information of like dealing with it on
top of that school was like where like
cal state was like where you been and
we're gonna do some like
oh and then also on top of that social
security like all this stuff it was just
like cool like if he wasn't there he's
not there well something
it took him like i think like four three
four months before he showed up and he
came with like his family all together
which kind of like i was just like why
don't you just come by yourself kind of
thing but
yeah i think maybe he needed his support
yeah he didn't support but then at that
point everything was just like go go go
go go just like
if if if yeah my mentality was just keep
going because there's there's no
stopping whatever just happened
do you feel like your mentality for just
always moving forward always moving
forward do you think that was like were
you always like that before the accident
or do you feel like that was kind of a
result of that no i wasn't like that
before definitely not but
it's like it was there was you were sad
as [ __ ] or something no i was just i was
happy but it's not like go go go get a
reason to like have that mentality yeah
that you think that motivated a more
survival
push forward mentality the accident and
everything yeah and also with just
having like i think
my my my my
my strength to find humor and things
kind of helped out like
that's cool all right next thing let's
do it let's do it like that all right
too much happiness let's get back to the
sex stuff
um how is sex nowadays oh
he's our he's our local sex person
like he's like that's where i would milk
it i mean i can't move too much so i get
on it you know
get on it
like ask me questions
that's the word on instagram don't
listen to the leader of quest crew over
here
i have to i just made that up i asked
you guys
yeah so how is it for you oh these are
great now dude [ __ ] yeah i think uh so
my
current girlfriend ladies girlfriend
she's great by the way yeah
she had this move and now you're about
to say soon to do something yes
okay
wait does she know that yeah she knows
that okay
she found this move and i was like oh
because like it's really hard for me to
come like it said before with the whole
yeah don't brag dude wow
she throws the bag like nothing yeah you
don't even know i was like
what what
how'd you how did this happen she's like
oh i was like all right
you can call her occupational therapist
you know what i'm saying
that's awesome man because that'd be
honestly like maybe
not the overly perverted side of me but
if i was like paralyzed
that would be one of the things i'd be
like [ __ ]
i know
because that's his life
coming up what he does
this guy does have sex
that's all he does
so the funny thing is that is that
coming just feels different overall
really i know i know some people yeah
i know some people
similar similar thing where it hurts too
so they don't want to come so it's like
a weird thing
does it hurt you still it's
sometimes it'll be like oh that's kind
of weird just like it says it's like a
big it's a big influx of just like
nerves going at it you know i thought
you just come so hard just [ __ ] just
fall on the ground because it's knocked
out of balance
standing always
because you turn the iron
legs i mean if you are you guys your
legs get a weak mind just go whoop and
i'm like on the floor
wow dude yeah what's the hardest thing
for you to do like at the phase of a
recovery you're out what's what's the
hardest thing for you to do still
maybe
oh the big the hard thing was me going
from right-handed to left-handed like
right now like oh you're left-hand
dominant now
can't open i'm trying i'm drinking
is that something you still actively
work work on
uh not anymore because right now give me
a bottle right yeah
once i figured out like oh this is great
for parties okay cool like functionally
like i could do this yeah i could drive
like oh i could grab like
i got the left hand for everything i
noticed that you had to open it first
and then you could so you could grab in
but then opening out as hard
you can play with this
it's okay that's my
[Laughter]
if you want to touch the head it's okay
it's like it's weird like it doesn't
want to like if you pull it to like open
it
it's like let me see it yeah it's just
extending it won't it won't extend it's
just curling whoa
the closest thing to that i can relate
to is i punched somebody in the face and
then it dislocated my uh knuckle
outside and then i had to pop it back in
and it was like it was like this
and then for i don't know like a month
or something i couldn't close it i
couldn't it just felt
it felt like um
like 50
usage oh so for mine's it's it's like
the muscles are flexed too much so i
need to make sure like i sh i like
yeah so like i don't want to do too much
exercise where it's always flexing then
it's i'm gonna be stuck like that so
that mean when you ask your girl like
hey can i get a hand job you're actually
just like he stretched me out
that's stupid
it's a good trick like they're like you
know go on dates or girls like hey like
can you stretch out this hand
wow
oh thanks thanks thanks
a smoothie yeah
ryan's like hey you want to take a trip
up to norcal do you go
[Laughter]
san francisco god
so what are we going up
right now let's go let's go let's go
easy easy
i'll take i'll take backseat this time
yeah you're the best i love that about
everything that has happened man you're
[ __ ] hilarious this dude here man
like if that happened to you this would
be the perfect rehab person i'm like tj
i need your help come here you've been
through this [ __ ] give me your hand joe
is it working is it working
which okay which hand joe which is
[Music]
h
[Music]
[Music]
you